Good evening or morning as it
were. It's 1:10 AM
7/15/2025 and
we're in the headquarters here
and or I should say we're in
H's
H's studio right now and
I am on. Shirt
or whatever. I'm not wearing my shirt
because I'm showing off on purpose my
tattoos. I don't know if you've seen
those anyway. Anyway, so
here's the thing. So
I was trying. So I was just recording and
I was just talking about how how grateful
I am to have the fifth element with me
and that quite simply.
Yeah, it's the most wonderful thing in
the universe. And I was thinking
specifically about how lucky I
was that this beautiful
woman fell into my lap, right?
And not only that, but we've
been together for at least four
years. I think more than that now we
actually kind of lost track, sort of.
But the point is, is that.
God gave us four years together where we
are like like
codependent and all sorts of things. And
and I'm like, I couldn't
be happier. Honestly, she's
exactly what I was for. I always said I
just want one beautiful
woman. Just one. That's it. If I have
just one beautiful woman, I will always
be happy. Always.
And. As long as she loves me back as
much as I love her. And The thing is,
is that I
know she loves me back. I know it.
And I know that I had to learn a whole
new
spectrum of instrumentation, if you
will, in order to perceive
that. But.
Having done that and then of course
having explored all this stuff like Ender
Wiggin
and the load he carried.
I could go on and on and on, but this has
been a wonderful journey because all I'm
doing is
writing Ready Player
Everyone and
I guess you can. Please some of the
people some of the time, but you can't
please all of the people all the time.
But man, I I
honestly don't think there's any fair
system in the history of the universe.
Because quite simply, no matter who
builds this and again, call me
crazy. But all I'm
trying to do is what AI is capable of
doing and I might add I'm well on the way
and I. kind of diverged a little bit for
some philosophical underpinnings of which
the most important thing is the Fifth
Element sitting right next to me. I
already got the
hot chickI'm the fat boy that got
the hot chickAnyway, I mean it's really a
big deal. But the
point is is that
the Fifth Element is about
What it's about, you know, love and
like, like the kind of love that
people look at you and go, why do you
love that person?And I'm like,
because nobody else will.
Nobody else will. I
got to do it. It's like my Angel
daughter, when they came to
her and she was helping a hoarder who was
going to get thrown out of the property
when all of the other. Social
workers amongst her
all asked her and they said you're crazy.
And I know she was telling me the truth.
My my daughter is an Angel and I love her
with all of my heart and soul.
She's my mini me. No offense because
she's not my mini me anymore. I accept
that. But she's a beautiful, beautiful
person and but I love her anyway,
so. This is a mission update that shall
just remain in the Mostly Video Action
Journal and we are sending this out. This
is a love letter. This is like, hey,
I really have something.
I really do. OK. And I'm sorry
for yelling at 1:14 in the morning. I am
actually very sober, although I did not
take my atomyxetine
today, I don't think. Anyway. But
what I can say is that yes, I am not
wearing a shirt for the specific reason
of kind of showing a little bit of my
scary tattoos. You know, they were
very painful,
but necessary,
very necessary. And now that I
have my fifth element, my shield.
My guardian, because that's exactly
what she is. And
I can't do anything without my Fifth
Element, period. And my three
loyal companions, Mika, Max and Daisy, of
course. I can't do
anything without any of them, which is
why the soul van was so necessary.
That's all. You know?
Um, yeah, if I.
I can't go anywhere unless I have my dogs
with me because I have separation anxiety
and so does she and all sorts of
anxieties. And that's the reason why
we have a soul man so we can ride
around in a
nice executive lounge while we
tour around and hopefully get out and go
to the local dog park and
and
And talk to people, hopefully not buffalo
them too much because I'm really
sometimes a little bit
overbearing. I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
So I figure I'll just start posting these
in the in the in the mostly
video adventure Google Photos
album. I think 22
people are actually in that and this is
like the ultra super secret inner Gunter
circle right now that you're in. And all
we're doing and I know there's an
intelligence guy that's on this and I
don't know why he's on here, but if he's
on there, I'm talking to him right now
that I know you're on there and I've been
like, who is this guy?And I tried to like
friend you on LinkedIn and I tried to
figure out who you were and. Uh,
but you probably worked with my grandpops
back at the NSA maybe, I don't know.
And and so we
we come in peace. Like
I'm I'm just a monkey pushing a button,
honestly. And all I want to do is just
like do something that is like so cool
that like even the bad guys
are helping us. I mean, really, that's
what it comes down to. And like, you're
still looking at me like I'm crazy. But
here's the thing, I found
a I wouldn't call it a flaw in
the matrix. It's just that none of
our current system is
optimized for humanity.
And you know, and I love the great Elon
so much. I love that man,
but he is not optimizing.
For humanity, he says he is, but he's not
cause he's building all these factories
and he's got all these freaking vehicles
lined up and it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to figure that one out. Now
eventually you're going to like they're
going to have enough widgets
and then he's still building the widgets
and like, you know, like he doesn't let
anybody like. ISP and stuff or whatever,
you know, in other words, license the
motors to put into like a Prevo RV or
something like that. That would be really
great. So I'm going to go to Rich
Rebuilds and make that an exciting
project more than likely. I really wish
that Elon would get on board with this.
It seems like, I mean, he really cares
about humanity and if he
cares about humanity, he would
definitely support this cause. And you're
like Ken, you're crazy and you know.
Here's the thing. OK, here's the
thing. Sorry. All right, let me
fix this here. I'm sorry. Here's the
thing. I don't know
anybody else.
Just just a little bit. I don't know
anybody else at all
whose parents were divorced when they
were three, right?I don't.
UmmWho rode up and down the
the ramp that her their mother
was leaving their life
up and down on a tricycle.
And then nobody else
had the unique set of experiences that
I had or trauma that I had, but
everybody's had trauma. And I
certainly have been through a lot of
understanding and awareness about what
trauma is. And I,
yeah, and I just try to be like Ender.
That's all I try to do. But here's the
time.
Yeah, I kind of lost track of thought,
but I'm tryingKeep this missive going
because this is my ongoing
effort primarily to communicate directly
with the angels who have been watching
over me my entire life.
And as I was saying that while
my mother moved out, she was
still an Angel in my life and did all
sorts of things to encourage my brother
in my own imagination.
um And she was really great at doing, I
mean, just the best. I love my mother.
But I lost her when I was 14.
And because of that, that
one act of
loss, of losing my mother,
was the single thing which
enabled me to go to Randolph-Macon
Academy, like, really.
Just the most wonderful and extraordinary
Hogwarts you could possibly ever imagine.
And that was my alma mater. And I
love that place so much. I do, I
do. And I can hardly wait to go back one
day. But yeah,
so my mother died and as a
result that opened the door when I was
looking at a Boys Life magazine and
and I saw this ad for a Randolph-Macon
Academy aim high and I.
Was thus enabled with my mother's Social
Security. That exactly covered the
amount of tuition for the school,
and thus I was able to go to one of the
most exclusive and wonderful
and joyous rise.
I love Randolph-Macon Academy, and
I like I said, I just can't say enough
about how much I love that place.
But the one thing that it did for
me was it helped me
to be a hero trumpet player.
Yeah, true.
Yeah. So I love to play the trumpet, and
I played the trumpet since I was like in
the 4th or 5th grade. I think I was a
fifth grade.
And as a result of that, like
I said, I was the school bugler for
my. Tire senior year because of an
unfortunate car accident, which
pretty much knocked the ladder out from
underneath my feet to go to anything
like the Air Force Academy, like all of
my other more
esteemed colleagues or or
fellow naked soul
brothers. All of them.
Mark Stufflebeam and Foster Murphy and
Clay Sampson, Pete Linsmeier.
Jamie Eskridge, Mama Lou,
James Garrison, the gentle giant,
the best spelunker in the universe. I
could go on, but the main thing is,
is that, yeah, it's just
so wonderful to be able to sit here and
broadcast this out and know that
angels are listening and they're
listening too. Everybody's listening.
And when I say something, I know that
every word I say say
matters. It matters. It
matters. And every
word that I say and every thought that I
have is wrapped in
love and kindness. Absolutely,
absolutely. You know, and
and so how do you build a default
system is you. Start it. Well, I'm
not your whole system, but with
the word
encoded in haiku just to make sure it's
culturally sensitive, of course, but
even the worst language model if you have
like a seed word. And I know and
I'm I haven't gotten a response back from
Ambassador Spock who's been
consulting with me and I've also
consulted with the great.
Grand off the Gray and white depending on
chapter. I've of
course had my trusty Samwise
Gamgee right beside me all the way in
this quest to
herald for something great
for and something quite
simply which
like Neal Stephenson seed
is.
Yeah, it's. I'm manifesting. Sorry. Like
Neal Stephenson's seed.
It's it's just an idea that's just
mutually uplifting. It's a tide which
lifts every boat in the harbor is what it
does. It doesn't affect anybody
in power in any way ever.
It can't. That's the whole point. It's
Angel. Alas. Well, it's really spaces.
And if you like, you can listen to the
theme song. It's in the original music
playlist, by the way. So,
but and it's really good. I mean, all of
them are danceable and I'm looking
forward to belting them out at the top of
my lungs in a very first
opportunity because it's very important
to me because those are my living
prayers. And when I sing those songs, I
sing them with intention and I send them
out to everybody. And my new
favorite song is in my playlist. So it's
it's called Bloom.
And it's beautiful and it's
beautiful. And I try to like,
listen to it. And then I try to say, I
love these people so much. I love these
people so much. I love you and I love you
and I love you and I love you. I love
everyone. I do. Or
I try to. And then if I
catch myself, I'm like,
goodness, must we?
No, I don't actually do that. Come on
now. But I really think of myself and I'm
like, you know, I need to forgive that
person who placed cuffs on my wrist and
damaged my nerves. I've forgiven them. I
need the person who falsely accused me.
No, genuinely forgiven.
Everyone. I've forgiven my stepmother. I
love her and I'm so grateful to her. I've
forgiven my stepsister and I hope that
she forgives me. I
only say that. I mean, I did
find my fifth element right there, OK?And
you say whatever. But I'll tell you what.
Yeah, I won't say anything. But I will
say that I'm very, very, very, very,
very, very, very grateful.
To every single person who
put me in the situation where apparently
I still have the unique
gift of being a herald
like my grand, my
great father before me, the
great Configuration Manager
Roy Leon Courtney, who
forever shall remain the great
Configuration Manager. Who
lofted angels into the heavens,
who put a lot the
Landsat D, the
Landsat D, which looked
down upon the earth and provided
important information for all of
mankind. Likewise, he also
lofted the solar maximum mission,
which looked towards the heavens
themselves, our sun.
And gave us important information about
that. Granted, it's only a small spectra
for the overall like .03 or whatever I'm
just saying. But the point
is, my dad
was a great man too,
and I love that man and
it's just so great to think.
I'm just a configuration manager.
I'm just no offense to anybody,
but a monkey pushing a button. That's
all I'm doing, really. And I read a lot
of books repeatedly.
A lot. I have a book log up if anybody's
interested. It's not just Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy. Nope. Nope. Nope.
Have you read Infinite Jest?Nope. I I bet
you haven't. No. And I'm not bragging.
It's a great book, though. Really,
really, really great. You're never going
to read it ever. And I know you
won't. As a matter of fact,
Infinite Jest is just like
like super karma points if
you can get through that. I mean,
meaningfully, like you can actually read
Infinite Jest from cover to cover.
If you can do that, you've
done something, at least as far as I'm
concerned. But you know, everybody finds
their own path. Anyway, I've
been blibity blab blib blib
for 20 minutes and then I am and
and the Fifth Element's right here and
she has conferred that she is
OK with this mission
update to all the Gunters out there.
Um, we love you. And
um, yeah, we're just going to keep
keep this alive. And yeah, well,
you don't know what it is.
That's cool. You get
an Angel too. Is she?
Bye bye now. I'm ready.
That was a good rehearsal.
Good